>> THE REVELATION OF THESE NEWS
IS DESIGNED TO GOAD TRUMP INTO
FIRING SOMEBODY.
FIRING MUELLER IS WHAT THEY ARE
SEEKING.
THEY WANT TRUMP TO DO SOMETHING
AFTER WHICH THEY CAN GO GET HIM
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T FOUND
ANYTHING YET TO GET HIM.
>> Sean: RUSH LIMBAUGH MAKING
A GREAT POINT EARLIER SAYING THE
BREATHLESS MEDIA COVERAGE OF THE
FBI RAID IS DESIGNED TO PROVOKE
THE PRESIDENT OF FIRE MUELLER.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE AUTHOR,
AND HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ IS WITH US.
I READ REPORTS YOU WERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
CAN YOU SHARE ANY DETAILS?
>> IT WAS A PREARRANGED,
PRESCHEDULED MEETING WITH
WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS REGARDING
THE ONGOING PEACE PROCESS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
I HAVE ADVISED EVERY PRESIDENT
SINCE BILL CLINTON ON ISRAEL.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE KNOW IT'S A
PASSION WITH ME.
TRYING TO RESOLVE THE
ISRAEL-PALESTINE CONFLICT IS
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
WRITING ABOUT, I'VE WRITTEN SIX
BOOKS ON THE SUBJECT.
I WAS SCHEDULED TO MEET WITH
STAFF MEMBERS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT WAS THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF
THE MEETING.
IT WAS NICE, I WAS INVITED TO
HAVE DINNER WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND A FEW OTHER PEOPLE.
WE DISCUSSED THE MIDDLE EAST AND
A RANGE OF SUBJECTS.
>> Sean: IT'S A SUBJECT WE
ALSO AGREE ON, BY THE WAY, AND
WE HAVE FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS WITH
THIS PRESIDENT DOING THINGS NO
OTHER PRESIDENT HAS DONE.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM SO MUCH
CREDIT.
WE GOT A LOT OF COMMENTARY ON
YOUR APPEARANCE LAST NIGHT.
YOU'VE TAKEN IT A STEP FURTHER
THAT THE RAID OF THE RESIDENCE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY AND HIS OFFICE
AT HOME AND HE WAS STAYING IN A
HOTEL I GUESS BECAUSE OF
CONSTRUCTION, THAT YOU SAY IT
VIOLATED A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
>> YOU CAN JUST GO AND SWEEP UP
ALL LAWYER-CLIENT PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION AND GIVE IT OVER TO
SOME FBI AGENT OR A LOW RANKING
U.S. ATTORNEY AND SAY GO THROUGH
IT.
THE STUFF THAT ISN'T PRIVILEGE,
TURN IT OVER TO PROSECUTORS.
THE STUFF THAT ISN'T PRIVILEGED,
YOU CAN READ IT AND STUDY IT BUT
YOU CAN'T GIVE IT TO
PROSECUTORS.
THE FOURTH AND SIXTH AMENDMENT
DON'T JUST PROTECT AGAINST USE
OF EVIDENCE IN A CRIMINAL TRIAL.
THEY PROTECT PRIVACY.
IMAGINE IF INSTEAD OF GOING INTO
CLIENT PRIVILEGE, THEY
TAPE-RECORDED A PERSON'S
CONFESSION TO A PRIEST OR RABBI
OR WENT INTO A HOME AND RECORDED
CONVERSATIONS OR CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN A DOCTOR AND PATIENT.
THE LAWYER-CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS
AS SACROSANCT AS THAT.
THERE HAS TO BE VERY GOOD REASON
OR FOR ANY PROSECUTOR SHOULD
HAVE A RIGHT TO LOOK AT IT.
>> Sean: YOU SAID, WHERE ARE
AMERICA'S CIVIL LIBERTARIANS ON
THIS?
AT SUCH A VIOLATION.
I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS.
I THOUGHT ROCHE, I WILL USE HIS
WORD, IT WAS RIGHT ON TARGET.
WHAT WE SEE THE PROSECUTOR DOING
HIS, BECAUSE THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, THEY SEEM TO BE
TRYING TO GOAD THE PRESIDENT.
HE DOES HAVE THE RIGHT TO FIRE
MUELLER.
THAT'S ESTABLISHED.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THEY WANT TO
PRECIPITATE SOME TYPE OF CRISIS
BECAUSE THEY FOUND NO RUSH OF
COLLUSION.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
WILL FIRE ANYBODY.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A
BIFURCATION OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK MUELLER HAS NOW
ACKNOWLEDGED HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO LOOK INTO
MR. DONALD TRUMP'S
PREPRESIDENTIAL ACTIVITIES.
SO HE HAS FILTERED IT OFF AND
GIVEN IT TO THE SEVENTH DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK WHICH IS GOING TO
INVESTIGATE THOSE ASPECTS
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THEY COULDN'T
FIND ANYTHING SUBSTANTIAL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PRESIDENT'S
EXERCISE OF HIS ARTICLE TO AUTHO
EXERCISE OF HIS ARTICLE TO AUTHI
EXERCISE OF HIS ARTICLE TO AUTHY
EXERCISE OF HIS ARTICLE TO AUTH.
HE HAD THE RIGHT TO FIRE COMEY
AND THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE WHAT
WAS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
HE WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PARDON, THOUGH I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD BE WISE TO DO AT THIS TIME
WOULD BE WISE TO DO AT THIS TIM
TIME.
BUT THEY ARE MOVING SOME OF THE
CASE OVER TO THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT TO LOOK INTO SOME OTHER
MATTERS REGARDING HIS LAWYER,
HIS PRIVATE ACTIVITY.
NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENTS.
SEEMS LIKE A SUBTERFUGE BY WHICH
MUELLER DOESN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY SO WE GET THAT TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
GIVES THEM THE INFORMATION.
IT IS LIKE LAUNDERING
INFORMATION TO ANOTHER
PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITY.
>> Sean: I MENTIONED THIS
EARLIER.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE GREATEST
DANGER, I THINK THIS IS WHERE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE COMES
IN IN TERMS OF THIS IS SO FAR
BEYOND A HIS MANDATE, B BY
GETTING INTO THE PRIVATE RECORDS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY.
AT THAT POINT, DOESN'T THAT
BACKDOOR MUELLER, EVEN THOUGH
IT'S THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK, RIGHT INTO EVERY
BUSINESS DEAL IN EVERY PRIVATE
AGREEMENT THE PRESIDENT HAS EVER
MADE?
>> HE IS TRYING TO HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS.
HE IS TRYING TO SAY I AM NOT
LOOKING INTO THIS BY GIVING THE
MATERIAL OVER TO THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT FOR THEM TO LOOK INTO
IT.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT NEVER
WOULD'VE GOTTEN THE MATERIAL BUT
FOR THE FACT THAT MUELLER
INVESTIGATED AND DISCOVERED SOME
OF IT.
IT'S A DANGEROUS THING TO START
INTRUDING INTO LAWYERS' OFFICES.
IT WOULD MAKE IT MUCH HARDER FOR
PEOPLE TO TRUST THEIR LAWYERS,
DOCTORS, PRIESTS, THEIR SPOUSES
WHEN PEOPLE SAY LOOK, EVEN THE
PRESIDENT'S MOST CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH HIS LAWYER
CAN NOW BE SEARCHED JUST BASED
ON PROBABLE CAUSE WHICH IS A
VERY, VERY LOW STANDARD, I THINK
THERE WILL BE GREAT DISTRUST OF
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO AMERICAN SOCIETY.
CONFIDENTIAL RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN A PRIEST AND A PENITENT
AND A DOCTOR AND A PATIENT AND A
LAWYER AND A CLIENT.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD DAY FOR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: WELL SAID, PROFESSOR.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A BUSY
24 HOURS.
YOU ARE WITH US LAST NIGHT, UP